[Music]
my name is Paulina Vega I'm from
Colombia South America I have no idea
how it was modeling and then Miss
Universe it was very unexpected it was a
surprise in my life and yeah I think
that because I did the opposite of a
pageant girl that's why I won okay I
don't know I've been I'm living here for
4 months now and my accent is just
getting worse I don't understand that I
miss everything about Colombia is the
food my people the culture uh my college
but but I will not change my life here
in New York for for nothing I know a
pageant girl going to college it's so
weird no but yeah I was starting
business administration and I will
continue that after this no but I really
have no idea when I was a little girl I
was like you're going you're going to be
like the owner of Coca-Cola but now
shocked to reality so I really don't
know you I was dreaming big you know
people dream big dream
[Music]
big